I'm gonna share with you how easy it is to make your own
homemade ketchup. Now,
I love eating the store bought main brand ketchup,
but I'm telling you, this tastes better.
I'm using heirloom tomatoes,
but you can pretty much use any tomatoes that you come across
from the store or in your garden.
I prefer heirloom tomatoes,
but it's totally up to you which type you use.
I did rinse these off in the vinegar bath in the sink,
and then I bought them over to my big stock pot,
and I'm gonna boil these just until they soften
so I can easily remove the skin.
There is other ways to remove the skin,
but this is just the way I'm doing it today.
I'm gonna use this food mill.
I did see this in a thrift store a few months ago
and I didn't even know what it was,
but I grabbed it anyway thinking
one day I will use you as I just love finding vintage kitchen gadgets.
So I use the mill to remove all the skin and the seeds,
and then I boiled the juices down for about three hours
until I was left with more like a paste substance.
This is what we're gonna use to make the ketchup.
Now to this, I'm gonna add a boatload of sugar.
If you didn't know, ketchup has a lot of sugar.
Most store bought ketchups have high fructose corn syrup in it.
Always read your Labels.
Then I'm gonna add a bunch of salt and seasonings.
You can add different seasonings to your ketchup for your preference.
If you like spicy ketchup,
you can add more cayenne pepper.
As I did add cayenne pepper,
but only half a teaspoon. Then I'm gonna add vinegar.
This is what's gonna help preserve the ketchup.
You need a high acidity level for cannon
and let that cook down again
until I get more of a ketchup like substance.
Once I'm happy with the thickness of the ketchup and then gonna can it.
I'm using my digital pressure canner.
But you don't have to use this.
You can just use a regular big pot to water bath.
I'm only water bathing these in here.
I'm not pressure canning them.
You don't need to pressure can tomato products
cause they have a lot of acidity in them.
Plus for the vinegar there is no need to pressure can.
I'm just gonna water bath these for 10 minutes in the digital canner.
I absolutely love this crochet canner.
It's one of my favourite things in the kitchen,
but definitely not necessary.
More of a luxury item. Once the cans were done processing,
I let them cool on the counter before I put them in the pantry.
The full recipe is available on my blog.